foreign
what's your name sir
oh
officer derosier San Antonio Police
Department if you're curious okay you
all right
no no
what happened
I am like
do you need an ambulance
no no I'm not is there anyone home that
can come out and help you out no I'm
I'm
sorry
do you realize your jeep's still running
oh shit your name Clayton yeah yeah okay
do you realize you were potentially
involved in a motor vehicle accident
tonight Clayton no
can you sit up no do you want help
sitting up no
I can't exactly leave you like this
oh shoot
man if you can't stand up on your own
I'm gonna have to call an ambulance
because I can't leave you with an
inability to care for yourself no
I'm sorry how about this try sitting up
let's start with that
all right
hey we're making progress
oh shoot do you have ID on you Clayton
no no I'm not and 412826 yes or no
question not a
Hammer aren't do you have ID on you no I
don't know do you have a driver's
license no
but you were out driving
no I'm not
no not right now but you were out
earlier now because I have a description
that you match out of Bill Millers
I have a receipt from right behind your
vehicle with some groceries from earlier
today okay and when I said you left your
vehicle running you reacted in such a
way that would lead me to believe that
you're operating it earlier
so if you don't have a driver's license
why are you out driving
oh shoot
let me ask another question
it appears that you might have been
driving while intoxicated if you don't
have a driver's license
that would be an even worse decision
wouldn't you agree yes okay can you
stand up no
have you been drinking tonight oh no I'm
just
trying to get into my
okay so why is that so difficult
well
sorry
it's an honest question
you know what time it is right now no I
don't even know what
foreign
who was
like well I I ask a lot of questions
that I already know the answer to yeah
so the more you lie to me just the
harder this is yeah for you easier for
me harder for you right so who's driving
not me not you no who was
and what kind of bum friend do you have
that would leave you lying in your
backyard
well
um back here and I just I'm sorry
I'm surprised you haven't even asked
about the people that you hit if they're
okay or not what yeah you were involved
in a more vehicle crash tonight at least
your vehicle was so I'm gonna call an
ambulance out because at this point I
can't just leave you here okay so we'll
go from there all right
thank you
you start me uh EMS to my location
let's start with your last name
Clayton Perry Clayton Perry yes
p-e-r-r-y yes what's your date of birth
sir
do you have a good phone number yes what
is that
um
well
okay
you know remember it well no I
have a warmer
I got that phone number
I'm sorry a good phone number
okay
well you think about that would you like
me to turn your vehicle off
yeah okay
don't go anywhere okay
do you have the key fob with you or is
it in the car somewhere
sorry do you have the key fob with you
or is it in the vehicle somewhere all
right it must have been okay I found
your wallet I'm presuming okay okay yeah
is it okay if I grab your driver's
license out of here yeah sure okay
so where were you coming from before
here
uh
uh do me a favor either have us eaten
the chair on the steps how about that
okay
[Music]
do you want to see yeah
[Music]
I just have a driver's license
[Music]
so what what happened this evening that
led us to hold on here
well
I just
came on home
from where from
um
yeah
okay
are you normally this fuzzy on details
no no no okay are you just avoiding my
question or are you confused no that's
more of a medical concern than anything
I'm just
uh
[Music]
had a good time
from
from
well okay
from
right
well
just right down
okay so you're having a good time right
down the road we're talking like Mud
Creek Elementary School Bill Miller like
we're how far down the road uh from
um
just right down there were you out of
business a friend's house hanging out on
the side of the road nope from um
see where was I
dang
when you were having this good time how
much did you have to drink
well I had a good time
what does that mean
just had a good time what does that mean
well had a good time
was it the people you were with the
beverages you were drinking the music
you were tapping your foot to like what
does that mean yeah had a good time
had a good time
okay
so who are we having this good time with
well from
well
shoot
just
a good time
okay I'll ask again I already know the
answer but I'm just waiting for you to
admit it who is driving your vehicle
tonight
well
I didn't have any anybody here tonight
because I mean you were driving your
vehicle tonight nope
enough to drive your vehicle but then
who's going to leave you laying in your
backyard
well I was
coming on home
right yep but who is driving nope not me
not you nope who was
well
there's a lot of acorns living here
tonight and a lot of acorns living here
yeah I mean
that has nothing to do with my question
though nope not me
we've established that
still waiting on who who was driving
nope not me do you realize that whoever
was driving ran into your garage
my garage
nope
just don't surprise you haven't asked
about the other car that you hit
my car another car that your vehicle hit
nope not me
okay
would you like your driver's license
back before you dip it inside
yes
can you get inside
yes
I appreciate it
just so you understand
I do have a crash report to write your
vehicle is going to be listed in that
crash report because that witnesses that
saw it occur and follows you back here
okay I'm also going to be filing a stock
failure to stop and provide information
okay so let's no matter what's happening
with all that
you have any questions for me okay nope
not for me go ahead and go inside
um just so you know the back tailgate of
your Jeep is open
and the window's down on the driver's
side okay all right now well I
appreciate it thank you very much yes
sir it's all right all right it wouldn't
happen inside all right
okay
I can't leave till I see you inside okay
I'm tired I don't think your keys are in
there if that's what you're looking for
okay all right keys are in the in the I
don't know where the keys are okay I'm
saying if you're looking for them I
doubt they're in your wall okay all
right well I appreciate it thank you
very much I appreciate it are you an
injuring your residence or no
I'm sorry are you gonna be entering your
residence or no yes
I got it thank you appreciate it
had there for your for a card to unlock
yeah that's a credit card
still no card that's gonna open that
door sir
just what there's no card that's going
to open that door
I've seen you try about six now well
it's just a standard lock you need a key
all right well
I know
well I'm sorry
me too I can't get into the into the
house
what do you want me to do
how far do you want me to check your
vehicle for Keys maybe you have a house
key that would try the front door
[Music]
well
the mystery driver take those too I'm
sorry or did the mystery driver run off
with those two yeah
I don't know I'm sorry can may I search
your vehicle for your house keys
the house keys were at your house
okay
yes I can search your vehicle for house
keys
well I need to get into the house the
door is locked usually Keys okay
um
hang on just a second I've been waiting
for a while I'm gonna ask one more time
after that I'm gonna leave you to your
own devices I'm sorry I'm gonna ask you
one more time if you answer no I'm gonna
leave you to your own devices because
you refuse to EMS they said that you're
competent to make decisions so yeah
would you like me to search your vehicle
for your house keys yes or no uh no
will do not drive anymore tonight